♪♪
Tim:
Your grandparents...
They created something extraordinary.
Tim:
They were fearless enough to believe
that the world is so
Tim:
much more vast than we
could possibly imagine.
Kentaro:
What's Monarch?
Verdugo:
Monsters are an inescapable reality
that we must learn to survive.
(Eerie sound)
Cate:
You knew these things existed?
This is your legacy.
(Roaring)
♪♪
The world is on fire.
Lee:
Something happened that Monarch didn't
want us to know about.
It's a map.
May:
Yeah, but what is it a map of?
Lee:
We can do this together.
We can figure it out.
(Roaring)
I'm not taking orders
from Monarch anymore.
Time to cowboy up.
(Screeching)
Lee:
Come on! Keep moving!
Verdugo:
We are looking at a wave of Titan events...
(Roaring)
...threatening the lives
of seven billion people.
What if the three could
of seven billion?
♪♪
(Screaming)
(Roaring)
(Screeching)